representative titus uh let's start with
the supreme court obviously there have
been several rulings at the end of the
of the term for the supreme court the
big one is with regards with uh abortion
what are you what discussions
have you had with your fellow democrats
on capitol hill
not only about the decision itself but
maybe a response from the democratic
side
well it's difficult to overturn anything
the supreme court does that's why this
is such a monumentous terrible decision
it was shocking that you turned back 50
years of constitutional rights but not
surprising given this court there's a
lot of conversation about creating
havens states states that have some
protections for abortion and don't have
those trigger laws that will
automatically go into effect and some
talk about having allowing abortions on
public lands but i think that's a little
more difficult to put in place we want
to be sure that there's funding for
birth control
in states where people might be going
because they can't get a divorce
abortion at home and plus you'll need
more birth control as as you uh plan
your future given the uncertainty of
what the court might do
obviously in nevada
the it's in the state law already
is
is it best for states to handle this on
their own and not have
a court case as the basis but state laws
whether it's in nevada california or
elsewhere
what is wrong with letting the states
determine what to do with regards to
abortion
if you let the state's determinant you
will have a patchwork across the country
with some states allowing it and some
not that's not the way you're supposed
to deal with fundamental rights so it
needs to be a national issue now the
court's taking this position i think
congress needs to pass a law uh
legitimizing abortion nationwide the
court might come back and strike that
down too but at least it would be a
start to put it into statute which is
more binding than what the states are
doing i suspect you're going to see a
lot of cases come before the court now
trying to strike down state laws
including the one in nevada that gives
us some protection in the short term
you kind of touched on this a little bit
with regards to your fellow democrats on
on capitol hill
even if there was an appetite among the
democrats to try and do something
legislatively in washington
i get the sensation and it wouldn't go
very far anywhere else so
is there is there anything that can be
done
well
yes there are some things we could do
away with the filibuster this will pass
out of the house it's in the senate then
it gets stuck where it takes 60 votes
that's just a rule it's not in law it's
not in the constitution you can get rid
of the filibuster and then you can move
a lot of things like the pro-act or some
gun legislation or equality act so
that's one thing you can do you can also
expand the court like roosevelt tried to
do during the new deal but that will be
uh more difficult i believe
is that something you would support
i would certainly look at it uh if you
expand the court then the democratic
president could make some more
appointments it seems to me ridiculous
that six people six people impose their
own will and their own beliefs on the
whole country when the great majority of
people in this country support keeping
roe intact
um that's obviously the main decision
from the supreme court there have been
some others today with regards to
environmental law in particular
um
just in general what has been your
reaction when you've heard these
decisions come down
from the supreme court were you
surprised uh angry uh trying to
articulate what you're feeling
as a democrat seeing these decisions
come down
well when it comes to constitutional
rights and that includes abortion but it
also includes equality it includes
voting it includes birth control
same-sex uh relationships all of those
are now up for grabs by this court and
even thomas said flat out now we need to
look at those things so that is shocking
and very concerning some of the
decisions that they reached the gun one
overturning a hundred year law in new
york about concealed carry it's one step
forward two steps back that's totally
contrary to the gun bill that we just
passed rolling back epa environmental
rela uh regulations uh
the ability of the epa to enforce some
of the things involving clean water and
clean air i mean what what kind of
decision is that as we face climate
change uh and then church and state
that's another one uh allowing private
money i mean
taxpayer dollars to go to support
private religious schools that's been in
place for
years and it goes back to the founding
fathers who made it very clear in the
constitution that there should be
separation of church and state so it's
just a real unraveling of the progress
that we've made in the last
five decades
is it possible though that
you know your whatever someone's stance
is on
any sort of issue that goes before the
supreme court
if you take the thought that their their
decision their rulings are based on law
is it possible that it's just bad law
and it needs to be litigated in a
different way or in a better way
well laws are never permanent they can
be changed by the next administration or
by the next congress or by by the court
so that's one of the great
uh assets of our government as is that
it is flexible to keep up with the times
i mean which founding father would have
imagined you could have drones or have
uh you know
wiretapping or things like that so it
has to be flexible but these decisions
that are coming down overturn
long-standing precedent long-standing
they overturn things that are supported
by a majority of the people
they go against what the
members of the court tried to portray
when they were getting uh confirmed to
leave it vague so that you might be able
to trick somebody like susan collins uh
so and not for all those reasons these
seem to be going counter to the arc of
history
final question when you when you get
back to uh washington
obviously you're also in the middle of a
re-election campaign how
how much of a of an issue will these
decisions be when you're on the campaign
trail and your fellow democrats for the
campaign trail
they'll be very important uh certainly
they energize the base women are very
fired up about the abortion decision
environmentalists care very much about
clean air and clean water as does
everybody but they're the active ones
you know that the gun lobby will wants
to keep the
keep things out of uh statute that
like my bump stock bill that they didn't
include in the senate bill and but the
other side with the gabby giffords group
and the brady group they're going to be
all fired up so i think these are
energizing
uh issues and if you look at me and my
opponent or democrats and some of their
crazy republican opponents you'll be
able to present a real contrast to the
voters so they can really make a choice
final question with regards to an issue
we've talked with you about before wild
horses
and the roundups uh particularly in
central northern nevada
any
update from your end uh on
on what has been going on with with blm
and i guess are you frustrated maybe
with the lack of of an update from from
the federal government
blm is very high bound it's hard to get
them to move and oftentimes they're
captured by ranching uh interest there
are several things going on one we're
asking for an investigation into the
entire program because you've had horses
catching uh respiratory diseases in the
holding pens and a number of them have
died so we want to look into that
another thing that i've been very
adamant and vocal about is the use of
helicopters to round up horses you saw
the visuals of the little coat that was
just chased down and died if you have to
round up some horses hire a cowboy they
know how to do it and be a lot cheaper
for taxpayer dollars and then the third
thing we're happy about this we got 11
million dollars in the house
appropriations bill to continue to
develop and distribute the birth control
method among the horses this is much
more humane and much cheaper uh than
rounding them up into holding pins that
last forever
is there and i know again you're up for
re-election right now is there a bit of
a
a time
concern that you have not maybe with
your own position but just broadly if
democrats lose control hypothetically of
the house
any
chance of something like
dealing with blm get it going forward
might get lost that's true uh some of
the western members of the house from
utah and wyoming montana they have a lot
of sympathy for cows eating public lands
grass but not much sympathy for horses
they say horses aren't native but
neither are cows and actually you can
trace a horse's ancestry back uh to
maybe they are native
uh that's all i have for questions
i was trying to do the math of like
native uh for horses um
i appreciate the time representative
thank you very much